driver slammed his van into a crowd of
worshippers overnight outside of London
mosque one person died at the scene but
it's not clear if his death resulted
from the ramming 10 others were injured
they were leaving the mosque after
Ramadan prayers police are treating the
crash as a terrorist attack the driver
tried to run away but was held by
onlookers until officers arrived a
witness says the man shouted that he
wanted to kill Muslims Elizabeth Palmer
is near the scene of the attack in North
London Liz good morning good morning
well 2017 has certainly been a cruel
year for Great Britain there have been
four terrorist attacks so far three of
them including the one that happened
last night just down the road behind me
here in London
this time the targets were Muslims who
were leaving the local Finsbury Park
mosque just after midnight following
Ramadan prayers witnesses say a man
shouting I want to kill Muslims drove
straight into a crowd of people they'd
gathered to help an elderly man who'd
fallen ill and collapsed that man later
died but it's not clear he was actually
killed in the attack Khalid
watched it happen turned left with no
indication with no even personally
that's deliberately left and they just
said the people and one of them he was
under the van we were gathered around
the van to actually lift the banner two
bystanders rushed to pin down the driver
of the rented van and held him until the
police arrived
he's a 48 year old man now under arrest
eight people were taken to the hospital
and this morning London's police
confirmed what everyone feared given the
methodology and given what was what was
occurring and what's happened the tragic
incidents across the country and this
had all the hole
after meeting with top British security
officials Prime Minister Theresa May
made this statement today we come
together as we have done before to
condemn this act and to state once again
that hatred and evil of this kind will
never succeed we heard again and again
the Prime Minister emphasizes a message
of solidarity violence can easily read
more sectarian violence and that's what
the great fear is the Muslim community
very much the phrase now has been told
they will get extra police protection at
least until the end of the holy month of
Ramadan charlie is my Palmer in London
Thank You Liz